>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
ON "TOP MODEL" LAST WEEK...
>> TODAY WE HAVE
A VERY IMPORTANT CLIENT--
FRANCA SOZZANI.
>> FRANCA CAN SHOOT YOUR CAREER
UP INTO THE STARS.
>> I DON'T LIKE BALANCING
(bleep) ON MY HEAD.
(bleep).
>> THE WINNER--BRITTANI.
>> (trilling)
>> I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT.
I KNOW I CAN TAKE
BETTER PICTURES
THAN EVERYONE ELSE.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
GORGEOUS.
HANNAH, A LITTLE LOST RIGHT NOW.
IT'S THAT THING SHE DOES
ALL THE TIME WITH HER FACE.
>> VERY--YEAH.
>> YEAH, IT'S THAT...
>>
OUI. OUI. OUI.
>> ALEXANDRIA AND HANNAH,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
ALEXANDRIA, YOU...
TOO MUCH CONTROL.
HANNAH, THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE--
LACKS CONTROL.
HANNAH.
ALEXANDRIA WAS SENT HOME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THREE GIRLS ARE LEFT--
MOLLY, HANNAH, AND BRITTANI--
BUT ONLY ONE WILL HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO DO YOU THINK
WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
(man singing in Arabic)
>> OH!
>> HOLY SHELLS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT,
THAT LEX IS GONE.
>> I CAN.
>> I CAN, TOO.
I KNEW IT WAS GONNA HAPPEN.
>> YEAH.
>> TODAY LEX WENT HOME...
>> HANNAH.
>> AND I'M SO EXCITED
BECAUSE SHE WAS DRAMA BITCH,
JUST CRAZY.
BUT IT'S A LOT HARDER
NOW THAT THERE'S
ONLY THREE OF US.
I KNOW MOLLY'S KIND OF
AHEAD OF ME PHOTO-WISE,
AND IF IT CAME DOWN
TO COMMERCIALS,
HANNAH WOULD BE AHEAD OF ME
COMMERCIAL-WISE.
SO I CAN'T BE MESSING UP
AT ALL ANYMORE
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE NOT FIRST,
YOU'RE LAST.
>> WOW.
BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
IS NOT FUN.
I'VE NEVER BEEN
IN THE BOTTOM TWO BEFORE,
AND I DON'T KNOW,
IT'S JUST STRANGE.
>> YOU HAVE HAD
SOME OF THESTRONGEST PICTURES
IN THIS COMPETITION,
BUT YOU HAVE TO BRING IT
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> I FEEL LIKE MY PICTURES
HAVEN'T SHOWN PR-PROGRESSION
LATELY, LIKE THE PAST TWO
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN
AS GOOD AS I CAN BE.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M (bleep) TOP THREE.
>> YEAH, IT'S INSANE.
>> I KNEW
I WASN'T GOING ANYWHERE.
>> BEING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
WOULD ALLOW ME
TO GET OUT OF HOUSTON.
IT'S HARD GETTING OUT OF A CITY
THAT DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MODELS,
AND I FEEL LIKE I'M MORE DYNAMIC
THAN BRITTANI AND MOLLY,
AND I'M SO MUCH MORE COMMERCIAL
AND I CAN DO HIGH FASHION.
I'M THE BEST OF BOTH WORLDS,
HONESTLY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH!
>> OH! OOH!
>> WHOA!
>> THAT'S KINDA BADASS.
"I'M TAKEN SOMEWHERE."
>> YOU SERIOUSLY LOOK LIKE
SIAMESE TWINS,
LIKE, AT THE HAND.
>> IT'S SO COOL, THOUGH.
THINKING ABOUT BEING
IN THE FINAL TWO,
IT'S JUST, LIKE, WOW,
'CAUSE I MEAN,
COMING OUT FROM A TRAILER PARK,
PEOPLE WOULDN'T EXPECT
MUCH OF ME
BECAUSE OF WHERE I COME FROM.
I JUST WANT TO SHOW THEM
THAT I CAN ACTUALLY BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BUT MOLLY HAS GOTTEN BEST PHOTO
THE PAST TWO TIMES.
SO I'M MORE THINKING, LIKE,
HOW CAN I MAKE MOLLY MESS UP
SO I CAN WIN?
>> UM, FINAL THREE.
THAT'S PRETTY AWESOME.
>> WE'RE FINAL THREE! AAH!
I DESERVE TO BE HERE MORE
THAN THEY DO, AND I KNOW IT.
I DEALT WITH
A LOT OF ABANDONMENT ISSUES,
UH, A LOT
OF KIND OF SELF-WORTH ISSUES
JUST BECAUSE OF ME
BEING ADOPTED, AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF OTHER GIRLS
IN MY POSITION
WHO, YOU KNOW, MAYBE DON'T THINK
THERE'S A LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL,
AND, YOU KNOW,
I CAN SHOW THEM THERE IS.
>> THIS HAS BEEN, LIKE,
SUCH AN INTENSE EXPERIENCE.
>> I UNDERSTAND LIFE
A LITTLE MORE
THAN BRITTANI AND HANNAH.
LIKE, BRITTANI--
SHE'S NEVER BEEN OUTSIDE OF,
LIKE, A TRAILER IN PENNSYLVANIA.
AND HANNAH--YOU KNOW,
SHE GOT KIND OF
THE GIRL-NEXT-DOOR,
THE LITTLE INNOCENT, LIKE,
"HEE HEE" GIRL THING,
BUT SHE GETS
REALLY EMOTIONAL ABOUT THINGS.
>> (crying) I DON'T WANT
TO COME ACROSS SPOILED
TO PEOPLE.
THAT'S... (sniffles and laughs)
(groans)
(crying)
>> AND BEING THROWN
INTO THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GONNA BE A LOT MEANER--
I THINK SHE'S GONNA
HAVE TROUBLE WITH THAT.
I THINK MY ONLY THING IS, LIKE,
I NEED TO STOP GETTING SO ANGRY.
BUT THAT'S KIND OF
JUST, LIKE, LIFE IN GENERAL.
>> MOLLY IS JUST ANGRY
ALL THE TIME.
MOLLY JUST DOESN'T MAKE LEMONADE
OUT OF LEMONS.
AND PEOPLE AREN'T GONNA WANT
TO WORK WITH SOMEONE
WHO DOESN'T BRING, LIKE,
A GOOD ENERGY
TO DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
>> BUT I'M REALLY, LIKE...
>> I CAN'T EVEN GET ANY MEAT
OFF OF THIS DAMN THING.
>> (chuckles)
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> YAY!
>> "TOMORROW YOU'LL KNOW BEAUTY
INSIDE, OUT AND ABOUT.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> MAYBE IT'S JUST
OUR BEAUTY SHOOT
AND OUR COMMERCIAL
FOR COVERGIRL.
>> MM-HMM.
>> ALL I KNOW IS
I BETTER GET MY BEAUTY REST.
>> UH-HUH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HI.
>> HEY.
>> OH, HELLO!
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> I JUST WANTED TO CHECK OUT
YOUR DIGS IN MOROCCO.
>> SO WE JUST FINISHED, LIKE,
CLEANING THE HOUSE
BEFORE MR. JAY WALKS IN.
>> I ACTUALLY HAVE
A SPECIAL NEWS ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM HOLLYWOOD.
>> OOH!
>> TAKE A LOOK.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HEY, GIRLS.
CONGRATULATIONS ON MAKING IT
THIS FAR IN THE COMPETITION.
MY NAME'S LARA SPENCER.
I'M HERE ON THE SET
OF "THE INSIDER."
AND AS A MODEL,
YOU MAY BE BOOKED FOR JOBS
AS A SPOKESPERSON
OR BE ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT FASHION TRENDS,
WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE--
TO GIVE YOU THE SCOOP
ON YOUR NEXT CHALLENGE!
EACH OF YOU WILL GET TO CHOOSE
A FASHION OR BEAUTY TREND
IN MOROCCO
AND REPORT BACK TO US
IN WHAT WE CALL A LIVE SHOT.
YOU'LL GET ONE HOUR
TO RESEARCH
AND WRITE UP YOUR QUESTIONS,
AND THEN YOU'LL GET
TO ASK EXPERTS OR ANYONE ELSE
WHO HAS EXPERIENCED IT.
BUT YOU NEED TO FILL 90 SECONDS
OF CONTINUOUS AIRTIME.
BACK TO YOU NOW
IN MARRAKECH, JAY.
>> THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
IS GONNA HAVE THIS LIVE SHOT
APPEAR ON theinsider.com.
THAT'S AN AUDIENCE
OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
SO THAT'S A HUGE DEAL.
>> I GOT REALLY EXCITED
WHEN I FOUND OUT
WHAT THE CHALLENGE WAS,
'CAUSE I'M LIKE,
OH, THIS IS GONNA BE FUN.
I'M GONNA GET TO LEARN
ABOUT MOROCCO.
LIKE, THIS IS WHAT I WANT TO DO.
I WANT TO MODEL.
I WANT TO SEE THE WORLD.
>> NOW HERE ARE
THE THREE SUBJECTS.
>> WE GET TO CHOOSE
FROM THREE PACKETS.
THERE WAS, UM, ARGAN OIL,
BLACK KOHL, AND HENNA.
AND SO I PICKED
THE BLACK KOHL ONE.
I HOPE I KNOW
WHAT BLACK KOHL IS.
I THINK OF BLACK KOHL
AND I THINK OF EYELINER,
AND I'M LIKE,
WHAT IF I'M TOTALLY WRONG?
WHAT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT THE HELL IS BLACK KOHL?
I DON'T KNOW. AAH!
>> SO THE BEST TIP
I CAN GIVE YOU--I ALWAYS SAY
YOUR THREE "W's."
IT'S WHERE ARE WE,
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT,
AND WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT IT?
ALL RIGHT?
SO YOU GUYS CAN GET READY,
AND I WILL SEE YOU GUYS
WHEN YOU GET BACK.
♪♪♪♪♪
(horn honks)
>> REALLY? IT'S GONNA RAIN?
(singsongy) WHAT THE HELL?
(normal voice) SO I GET
TO THE LOCATION, AND IT'S, LIKE,
THIS LITTLE SPICE PHARMACY
WITH ALL THESE DIFFERENT SPICES
AND HERBS AND DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE COME IF THEY'RE SICK.
AND THERE'S THIS GUY ABDUL,
AND HE IS, LIKE, THE SPECIALIST.
I JUST TO, UM...
>> YES?
>> FIND OUT
ABOUT THE BLACK KOHL.
YES.
>> WE HAVE, UH, LIKE,
AN HOUR TO RESEARCH,
AND THEN WE HAVE TO FIND
SOME RANDOM PERSON
OFF THE STREET TO INTERVIEW.
AND THAT'S KINDA HARD.
WE'RE IN MOROCCO.
BARELY ANYONE SPEAKS ENGLISH.
(singsongy) CRAP!
>> EXCUSE ME.
DO ANY OF YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
>> NO.
>> NO ENGLISH?
EXCUSE ME. DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
NO?
SHOOT ME!
HI. DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
SO I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
TO INTERVIEW ABOUT HENNA,
AND NOBODY SPEAKS
(bleep) ENGLISH.
HI. DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
>> SPEAK ENGLISH.
>> A LITTLE BIT?
DO YOU KNOW MUCH ABOUT HENNA?
>> HENNA, YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HENNA?
WOULD IT BE OKAY
IF I INTERVIEWED YOU?
AND SO I FOUND THIS MAN
SELLING CANDY, AND HE TELLS ME,
"YES, I SPEAK A LITTLE BIT."
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO.
HAVE YOU KNOWN MANY PEOPLE
WITH HENNA?
>> HE DON'T SPEAK, UH, ENGLISH.
>> WELL, NOW WHAT THE HELL
AM I GONNA DO?
AND SO MY PLAN OF ACTION IS
FOR ME TO JUST DELIVER
ALL THE FACTS
AND THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE IF I LET
SOMEONE ELSE SPEAK,
THEY'RE GONNA TALK TOO LONG
AND THEN (bleep) ME OVER.
LET'S DO SOME RUN-THROUGHS HERE.
>> I'M HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU
A BEAUTY--
THE BEST-KEPT BEAUTY SECRET
OF MOROCCO, WHICH IS ARGAN OIL.
I GET ARGAN OIL.
AND I'VE STUDIED JOURNALISM
IN COLLEGE,
SO I COULD REALLY, REALLY NAIL
THIS ONE,
AND I'VE NEVER WON A CHALLENGE,
SO THIS IS AWESOME.
>> BUT THE SPECIALIST
STARTED TALKING FOR,
LIKE, A MINUTE.
AND I WAS JUST, LIKE,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SAY, LIKE,
ONE OR TWO SENTENCES,
'CAUSE I CAN'T
GO OVER 90 SECONDS.
I'M READY.
BUT I FEEL IT.
I KNOW I CAN DO THIS.
>> HANNAH, FOR THE TAKE,
I'LL HOLD UP--
YOU HAVE 60 SECONDS LEFT.
>> OKAY.
>> 30 SECONDS LEFT.
>> AND THEN TEN SECONDS,
YOU WRAP IT UP.
>> GREAT. GREAT.
>> (sighs) OKAY.
LET'S JUST DO IT.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO ROOM
FOR MISTAKES
BECAUSE IF I DO BAD,
THEY'RE JUST GONNA BE LIKE,
"WELL, ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
CAN MODEL, BUT THEY CAN
DO COMMERCIALS, TOO,
AND YOU CAN'T. SO SORRY,
YOU'RE NOT THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
YOU GO HOME."
>> WILL YOU BE READY?
'CAUSE WE HAVE TO DO THIS
REALLY QUICKLY.
I WAS JUST SO SCARED AND, LIKE,
AAH!--ALL OVER THE PLACE.
LET'S JUST DO THIS.
IT'S GONNA BE (bleep).
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT JUST
KINDA DEPENDS
ON HOW BRITTANI AND HANNAH DO.
I'M HOPING THAT THEY SUCK.
>> AT THIS POINT,
IT'S ABOUT WHO'S GONNA
BREAK DOWN UNDER PRESSURE...
>> I'LL COUNT YOU DOWN
FROM FIVE.
>> BECAUSE ANY LITTLE ERROR
COULD BE THE FINAL STRAW.
>> FIVE...
>> FOUR...
>> THREE, TWO...
(snuffles)
>> HOW'D IT GO?
>> HEY.
>> PRETTY WELL.
>> AWESOME.
WE GET BACK TO THE HOUSE,
AND JAY'S WAITING FOR US.
WE HAVE TO WATCH
ALL OF OUR VIDEOS.
I THINK IT'D BE REALLY AWESOME
TO WIN THIS CHALLENGE
'CAUSE YOU GET YOUR VIDEO
ON "THE INSIDER" WEB SITE,
AND SO THAT'S EVEN MORE EXPOSURE
AND PEOPLE SEEING YOU
AND BEING LIKE, "WOW.
SHE CAN DO MORE THAN
JUST WALK A RUNWAY
AND TAKE PRETTY PICTURES."
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> HI, I'M BRITTANI
FROM "TOP MODEL,"
AND I'M HERE WITH
EL MAHI--MR. YOUSSEF
AT THE AHERBALAS PHARMACIA
IN, UM,
HERE IN MARRAKECH, MOROCCO.
AND I AM HERE REPORTING
ON THE FIERCEST TREND--HENNA.
HENNA IS A TRADITION
TYPICALLY DONE
AFTER A WEDDING CEREMONY,
AND IT HAS BEEN USED
SINCE THE 7th CENTURY
AS HENNA ON THE FEET
AND THE BODY.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
OF MARRAKECH, IN THE MEDINA,
THINK ABOUT HENNA.
THANK YOU, YOUSSEF.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> BRITTANI'S VIDEO WAS
A LITTLE BIT
OF A SHOOT-AND-MISS.
AT ONE POINT, BRITTANI, LIKE,
RUNS AWAY FROM THE CAMERA,
AND THE CAMERA'S, LIKE,
FOLLOWING HER
THROUGH THIS HALLWAY.
>> HI. I'M BRITTANI.
SO WOULD YOU SAY THAT HENNA
SYMBOLIZES BEAUTY
AND TRADITION?
>> YES.
>> AND IT'S A WEDDING CEREMONY
WITH--ALMOST EVERY WOMAN IS
OBLIGATED TO WEAR THE HENNA?
>> YES.
>> SHE'S LIKE, "SO YOU LIKE
THE PRODUCT, RIGHT?"
AND HE'S LIKE...
(imitates Middle Eastern accent)
"YES."
(normal voice) AND THAT'S,
LIKE, IT.
>> HENNA IS USUALLY USED
ON THE HANDS AND THE FEET.
AND SO THERE YOU HAVE IT,
HOLLYWOOD.
REPORTING FROM MARRAKECH--
>> WOW. (laughs)
OKAY, FIRST OFF,
RIGHT OFF THE TOP,
YOU KIND OF SET UP
WHERE YOU WERE
AND WHAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT,
SO THAT WAS GOOD.
BUT THEN YOU HAD
THIS EXPERT STANDING THERE,
AND YOU WENT, "OKAY, THANK YOU."
AND IT'S, LIKE, YOU DIDN'T
EVEN UTILIZE YOUR EXPERT.
AND WHEN YOU RAN
THROUGH THE STORE
AND ALL THE WAY OUTSIDE,
>> THAT ATE UP ABOUT
TEN SECONDS OF YOUR TIME...
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> AND SO YOU WERE UNABLE
TO FINISH YOUR REPORT.
WELL, LET'S SEE WHO'S NEXT.
>> HEY, Y'ALL. THIS IS MOLLY O.
REPORTING FROM
BEAUTIFUL MARRAKECH, MOROCCO.
WE ARE IN WHAT IS CALLED
AN HERBORISTERIE ESSALAME,
WHICH IS KIND OF LIKE
A PHARMACY FOR SPICES.
SO WE HAVE HERE ABDUL
AND NADIA.
>> HELLO.
>> ABDUL IS AN EXPERT
ON BLACK KOHL.
IT'S A POWDER--OR IT'S A STONE
THAT CAN BE CRUSHED
INTO A POWDER, AND IT'S FROM
THE SAHARA DESERT.
IT'S USED FOR
FOR MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
SO WHAT KIND OF THINGS
IS IT USED FOR, NADIA?
>> (speaks Arabic)
>> SHE SAID, "KOHL IS VERY GOOD
AS EYELINER.
AT SAME TIME,
IS ANTISEPTIC."
>> OKAY.
WELL, COULD YOU SHOW US
HOW IT IS PUT ON WOMEN?
>> YES.
>> IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT TO ME
TO WIN THIS CHALLENGE.
YOU KNOW, IF I WIN,
I GET TO BE ON theinsider.com.
LIKE, SO MANY PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT COUNTRIES,
YOU KNOW, GO ON THAT WEB SITE,
AND I'LL HAVE
MY LITTLE SEGMENT ON THERE.
THAT MAKES THE EYES
LOOK SO PRETTY.
IT REALLY MAKES THEM POP
AND BRIGHTENS THE EYES.
IT--YOU CAN HAVE
A FIERCE SMIZE WITH THAT ON.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
THANKS, YOU GUYS.
>> YOU ARE VERY WELCOME.
>> THANKS.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> (laughs)
>> YEAH.
>> AWESOME.
>> (chuckles)
THAT WAS HORRIBLE.
>> (laughs)
>> MOLLY, YOU ARE ON
UNTIL IT'S CUT.
I MEAN, IF WE'RE LIVE,
WE'RE WATCHING THAT.
WE'RE SEEING THAT WHOLE BIT.
>> THAT'S SO BAD.
AND I'M LIKE,
SHE'S TOTALLY KNOCKED OUT.
SO I'M LIKE, YES!
I'M GONNA WIN THIS.
>> SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT YOU GOT THERE, HANNAH.
>> I'M EXCITED.
HELLO, OR SHOULD I SAYSALAM?
I'M IN MOROCCO, MARRAKECH,
AT ESSENCE DESSINS,
AND I'M GONNA SHARE WITH YOU
A FAMOUS BEAUTY TIP
FROM MOROCCO.
IT'S ARGAN OIL.
IT'S 100% ORGANIC,
RICH IN VITAMIN C--
OR VITAMIN E AND FATTY ACIDS,
WHICH ADD TO ITS ANTIAGING,
CONDITIONING, AND, UM,
JUST WONDERFUL PROPERTIES
THAT MAKE IT USEFUL
FOR BOTH MEN AND WOMEN.
HELLO, SANA.
>> HELLO.
>> DO YOU MIND TELLING US
HOW MULTIFUNCTIONAL,
UH, ARGAN OIL IS?
>> ARGAN OIL IS GOOD FOR SKIN,
FOR BODY, FACE, AND HAIR.
>> I THINK THIS MIGHT BE
HANNAH'S CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE I MEAN, SHE'S INTO
THE WHOLE ACTING THING
AND TALKING
IN FRONT OF A CAMERA.
>> UH, WELL, CORAL,
YOU CAME HERE TO GET ARGAN OIL
TO HELP CONDITION YOUR HAIR
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
DO YOU LIKE IT?
YEAH, I REALLY LIKE IT.
MY HAIR WAS PRETTY DRY.
>> WOW. IT LOOKS FABULOUS.
SO NO DRECKITUDE HERE,
JUST SMIZE,
'CAUSE YOU LOOK FABULOUS
AFTER YOU--
>> (laughs)
>> OH.
>> SO YOU ALSO HAD
A BIT OF AN ISSUE WITH TIME
THERE AT THE END.
>> YEAH.
>> AND IT WAS KINDA LIKE
YOU WERE TURNING
TO THE PEOPLE WHO WERE WITH YOU
AND YOU DIDN'T ALLOW THEM
TO KIND OF EXPLAIN.
FOR INSTANCE, EVEN THE--
THE YOUNG WOMAN FROM HOLLAND...
>> MM.
>> YOU TOLD US
WHY SHE WAS THERE
INSTEAD OF JUST ASKING HER
WHY SHE WAS THERE.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
THAT WAS, UM,
INTERESTING TO WATCH, RIGHT?
BUT YOU KNOW,
WHAT I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR IS
SOMEBODY THAT I GOT
ALL THE INFORMATION FROM,
WHO UTILIZED THE PEOPLE,
AT THE SAME TIME,
GAVE ME PERSONALITY.
SO IN MY OPINION,
IN TERMS OF THE PERSON
WHO NAILED EVERYTHING
AS BEST THEY COULD
IN THOSE 90 SECONDS,
I'D HAVE TO SAY...
(drumroll)
>> WAS MOLLY.
>> YEAH!
>> SO THIS IS A HUGE DEAL.
>> I FINALLY WON SOMETHING!
(singsongy) I WIN THE CHALLENGE!
(normal voice) HA HA HA HA,
BITCHES.
FINALLY, I WIN ONE.
I'M STEPPING UP MY GAME.
I'M DOING REALLY WELL.
LIKE, I'M GONNA WIN THIS.
>> THAT WAS--
THAT WAS A REALLY GOOD JOB.
>> (voice breaking) IT'S JUST
SO FRUSTRATING WHEN I FEEL LIKE
TODAY'S CHALLENGE WAS
TOTALLY UP MY ALLEY.
>> BYE. I'LL SEE YOU GUYS SOON.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> AND IT MAKES ME, LIKE,
SECOND-GUESS MYSELF
A LITTLE BIT.
BUT HONESTLY, IN MY HEART,
I FEEL LIKE I DID WIN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HI, LADIES.
>> OH!
>> HI!
>> HELLO.
>> WE GET A VISITOR,
AND IT'S TYRA.
>> GIVE ME A HUG.
>> AND IT WAS REALLY AWESOME.
SHE WASN'T, LIKE, TYRA BANKS,
WHO'S GONNA EITHER
MAKE ONE OF US A SUPERMODEL
OR JUST SEND
THE REST OF US HOME.
>> SO WHAT'S UP?
ARE YOU HOMESICK?
>> YEAH, A LITTLE BIT.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK WE'RE ALL
KIND OF READY
BUT NOT READY AT THE SAME TIME.
>> MM-HMM.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS PERSONALLY
RIGHT NOW?
>> PRETTY GOOD. I MEAN...
>> STRESS?
A LITTLE STRESS, DEFINITELY,
ALWAYS, I MEAN, IT'S...
>> WHAT DID YOU OPEN UP ABOUT
AT THE EMOTION DAY
FOR THE ACTING CHALLENGE?
>> UM, KIND OF, LIKE,
MY ADOPTION...
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND THAT, LIKE, FEELING
OF BEING, YOU KNOW, NOT WANTED.
(crying) YOU NEED TO STOP
THINKING THAT YOU'RE UNWANTED
JUST BECAUSE YOUR MOTHER
GAVE YOU AWAY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT THEN ALSO, LIKE,
MY--MY ADOPTED PARENTS
JUST UNCONDITIONALLY LOVING ME
AND JUST THE STUFF
THAT I'VE PUT THEM THROUGH,
LIKE, YOU KNOW,
DID DRUGS IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I WOULD GO OUT AND STAY OUT,
AND I WOULDN'T LISTEN TO THEM.
>> MM-HMM.
>> (crying) AND THEY
DIDN'T DESERVE THAT
'CAUSE THEY'RE THE BEST PEOPLE
I'VE EVER KNOWN.
I'M KIND OF A BRAT AND I BITCH
AND, YOU KNOW, I MOAN,
BUT I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S WHAT I DO TO HIDE
MY SADNESS.
>> DID ANYBODY EVER TALK TO YOU
ABOUT, LIKE, WHAT PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ABANDONMENT ISSUES DO?
>> YEAH, SABOTAGE THINGS...
>> THEY SABOTAGE AND THEY...
>> AND THEY PUSH THE LIMITS.
>> AND THEY'RE PUSHING.
YOU'RE TESTING THEM TO SEE,
ARE THEY GONNA ABANDON YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU WANNA ALMOST
LEAVE THEM
BEFORE THEY LEAVE YOU, RIGHT?
>> YEAH, AND THAT'S WHAT I DID.
AND--
>> BUT THEY DIDN'T GO ANYWHERE.
>> NEVER.
>> YEAH.
>> AND THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
JUST SUCH AMAZING PEOPLE.
>> AND WHAT DID YOU, UM...
>> IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I ALWAYS FELT LIKE
I WASN'T ENOUGH FOR MYSELF.
AND BEING HERE, IT'S, LIKE,
I'VE ACTUALLY REALLY COME OUT
OF MY SHELL A LOT,
AND IT'S HELPED ME A LOT MORE,
JUST, LIKE,
EMBRACING MY GOOFY SIDE.
>> AND I SEE IT IN YOUR FACE,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SOME KIND
OF REBIRTH,
LIKE A NEW LIFE OR SOMETHING.
>> IT'S GREAT.
IT'S A DEFINITELY A GOOD CHANGE.
>> AND WHAT WAS YOUR STRUGGLE?
>> WELL, MY MOM HAS
SEVERE PANIC/ANXIETY DISORDER,
SO SHE CAN'T REALLY WORK
'CAUSE FOR THE FIRST FEW YEARS
OF MY LIFE, SHE WAS AGORAPHOBIC,
AND SO SHE--
>> FEAR--FEAR TO LEAVE
THE HOUSE, RIGHT?
>> YEAH, SHE DIDN'T LEAVE
THE HOUSE.
SHE JUST STAYED INSIDE
AND DIDN'T DO MUCH.
(crying) AND SO GROWING UP,
I WAS KIND OF ALMOST EMBARRASSED
'CAUSE KIDS WOULD MAKE FUN OF ME
'CAUSE MY MOM HAD PROBLEMS
AND SHE DIDN'T HAVE A JOB,
AND PEOPLE WOULD JUST LABEL ME
AND THEN... (sniffles)
IT'S JUST, LIKE--
>> WHENEVER I SEE TEARS,
I CAN'T...
>> YEAH. (chuckles)
>> IN THE JUDGING ROOM,
IT'S SO HARD FOR ME
TO STAY BEHIND THE TABLE.
>> ESPECIALLY BEING AWAY
FROM HER NOW,
IT'S REALLY MADE ME REALIZE
HOW MUCH I LOVE HER
AND APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
SHE'S DONE FOR ME,
BECAUSE SHE'S THE ONE
THAT GOT ME INTO THIS.
>> MM-HMM.
TO ME, IT'S ALL RELATABLE.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS SAY
THAT PERFECT IS BORING.
AND JUST--A LIFE THAT'S
JUST, LIKE, LA-DI-DA
MAKES FOR A WOMAN THAT,
TO ME, IS VAPID,
AND DOESN'T APPRECIATE THINGS.
AND THERE'S GIRLS LOOKING AT YOU
LIKE, "OH, MY GOD, MOLLY--
LIKE, THAT'S ME,"
YOU KNOW, "BRITTANY--THAT'S ME,"
"HANNAH--THAT'S ME"--
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF YOUR LOOK,
NOT BECAUSE OF THE PICTURES
THAT YOU TAKE,
BUT BECAUSE OF THE STRUGGLE
THAT YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH.
IN-INSIDE, YOU'RE JUST LIKE
EVERY OTHER GIRL.
>> I DIDN'T REALIZE
HOW MUCH TYRA DOES CARE
ABOUT US AS PEOPLE.
AND TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN
REALLY MADE ME FEEL GOOD.
>> COME ON OVER, LADIES.
I'M GONNA PHOTOGRAPH YOU GUYS
RIGHT NOW.
>> (gasps) OH, MY GOSH.
>> YES.
SO I'M GONNA SHOOT YOU GUYS,
AND THIS IS GONNA BE, LIKE,
SUPER-DUPER FAST.
I'M DOING YOUR MAKEUP.
SMOKY EYE.
WE JUST CAME UP
WITH SOMETHING, GUYS.
I'M DOING YOUR HAIR.
NOW COMES THE GREASY GREASE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE HELL
TO GET OUT.
>> OH, LORD.
>> WE'RE STRUGGLING
A LITTLE HERE,
BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT WORK.
AND I'M PHOTOGRAPHING YOU.
JUST GIVE ME FACE,
WHATEVER YOU FEEL.
>> YOU KNOW, I LOVE HANNAH
AND I LOVE BRITTANI.
THEY'RE BOTH SO AWESOME.
BUT I WANT BRITTANI TO GO HOME,
BECAUSE IN RUNWAY,
BRITTANI IS MY COMPETITION.
>> PERFECT!
>> BUT I HAVE TO WIN.
I DON'T LIKE LOSING.
THERE--THERE'S REALLY
NO OTHER OPTION FOR ME.
>> ♪ AND HERE WE GO AGAIN ♪
>> YES.
PROVE TO THE WORLD
THAT YOU ARE NOT JUST
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
JUST TINY, MICRO MOVEMENTS.
TINY, MICRO MOVEMENTS.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I FEEL LIKE
THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS,
I HAVEN'T REALLY SHOWN,
LIKE, A STRONG PICTURE,
AND I FEEL LIKE BRITTANI
AND MOLLY HAVE KIND OF STARTED
TO FORGET ME AS COMPETITION,
BUT I KNOW I CAN KICK THEIR ASS,
AND I DEFINITELY KNOW
TYRA'S SEEN IT IN ME.
>> PARENTS NEXT DOOR
SHOULD NOT TRUST
THEIR YOUNG'UNS WITH YOU.
>> ♪ HERE WE GO AGAIN ♪
>> BRITTANI.
I'M--I'M SORRY.
STRETCH YOUR NECK A LITTLE.
YEAH... (speaks indistinctly)
WHATEVER YOU FEEL. LOVE THAT.
>> THE WHOLE COVERGIRL
AND IMG, ITALIAN "VOGUE"
PRIZE PACKAGE IS INCREDIBLE.
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S A POSSIBILITY FOR ME
BECAUSE IT SEEMS
SO FAR OUT OF REACH
BECAUSE OF WHERE I'M FROM.
>> YEAH, SMIZE.
>> BUT YET, AT THE SAME TIME,
ALL I HAVE TO DO IS, LIKE,
REACH OUT AND GRAB IT,
AND I CAN HAVE IT.
>> LOVELY. WE GOT IT!
NOW THERE'S ONE THING
ABOUT MODELING
THAT I WANT YOU ALL
TO TAKE AWAY,
AND IT'S ISOLATION.
WHEN I WAS SHOOTING YOU
AND I WAS LIKE,
"GIVE ME YOUR NECK,
GIVE ME YOUR EYES
OR JUST MICRO MOVEMENTS,"
AND THE BEST MODELS IN THE WORLD
CAN ISOLATE
AND DO ONE THING AT A TIME
AND NOT MOVE SOMETHING ELSE,
RIGHT?
LET'S START WITH OUT HIPS,
ISOLATING OUR HIPS.
OKAY, 'ROUND AND 'ROUND
AND 'ROUND AND 'ROUND.
OKAY, NECK AND NECK
AND NECK AND NECK.
FOLLOW ME FOR THE NECK
AND THE HEAD.
JUST THE HEAD.
ISOLATION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> NECK.
NECK.
>> AFTER WE SHOT WITH TYRA,
WE GET TO THE ROOF,
AND THERE ARE THESE, LIKE,
TRADITIONAL MOROCCAN MEN
PLAYING MUSIC AND DANCING.
>> GOOD MODELS...
ISOLATE.
>> IT WAS JUST CRAZY,
'CAUSE, LIKE, WE WERE ALL
SO HAPPY AND LAUGHING.
>> JUST BOOGIE! YEAH, COME ON!
>> I REALLY LOVE BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THOSE MOMENTS,
BECAUSE THE COMPETITION
JUST TAKES SUCH A TOLL
ON YOUR EMOTIONS.
>> AND MOLLY!
>> I'M SO GRATEFUL
FOR THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
AND THIS WHOLE OPPORTUNITY.
>> YEAH!
>> LIKE, I'VE BEEN
AT AN ALL-TIME LOW BEFORE,
AND JUST LOOK WHERE I AM NOW.
>> GO, HANNAH!
>> IT'S GETTING CLOSE
TO THE END,
AND I KNOW THAT I AM CAPABLE
OF--OF GREATNESS.
I KNOW IT.
>> OH!
(speaks Arabic)
>> ♪ THE NEXT TIME ♪
♪ I'LL SEE YOU ♪
♪ THERE WILL BE ELIMINATION,
AND THERE WILL ONLY BE TWO.
>> AND SO NOW IT'S JUST
WHO'S GONNA FIGHT FOR IT
THE HARDEST.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> OH, SNAIL!
>> "ARE YOU REALLY COMMITTED?
YOU WILL BE TOMORROW.
LOVE, TYRA."
LIKE, COMMITTED
TO AN INSANE ASYLUM--
THAT'S WHAT I THINK
IS "COMMITTED."
CRAZY PEOPLE.
>> REALLY?
>> IT'S REALLY FUNNY
THAT'S WHAT YOU THINK
WHEN YOU HEAR "COMMITTED."
♪♪♪♪♪
(chirps)
>> IS IT YOUR STOMACH?
>> UH, YEAH.
>> IT'S ALL-OR-NOTHING
AT THIS POINT.
I'VE BEEN TO HELL AND BACK.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH, YOU KNOW,
DEPRESSION, ANXIETY.
I'VE BEEN TO REHAB,
YOU KNOW, AND THIS WILL
REALLY BE A JUMPSTART
FOR MY LIFE, AND I NEED IT.
I NEED IT BADLY.
I JUST WANT TO MODEL.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> OH, LOOK
WHO FINALLY SHOWED UP.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> DOING WELL.
>> WELCOME TO ESSAOUIRA.
THIS HAPPENS TO BE THE JEWEL
OF THE MOROCCAN COASTLINE.
>> TODAY'S YOUR CHANCE
TO REALLY PROVE TO US
IN THE FINAL THREE,
THAT YOU CAN BRING A STORY
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS.
>> YOU'RE GONNA BE STYLED
WEARING MOROCCAN WEDDING GOWNS.
YOU'RE ALSO GONNA BE MODELING
WITH A MALE MODEL
WHO POTENTIALLY
COULD BE THE GROOM,
HE COULD BE THE BEST MAN,
BUT I WANT YOU TO RUN WITH IT.
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT
WORKING WITH THE MALE MODEL,
BECAUSE I DON'T REALLY KNOW
HOW I'M GONNA DO WITH HIM
IF HE GETS TOO CLOSE TO MY FACE.
I KNEW ALL THE LINES
FOR OUR FIERCE ROAST COFFEE
COMMERCIAL.
IT WAS THE SEXY THING
I DIDN'T QUITE NAIL.
>> TODAY'S SHOOT IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SOMEBODY'S GOING,
AND IT'S THAT ONE SHOT
THAT'S GONNA KICK THAT GIRL OUT.
SO LET'S HEAD BACK UP
TO THE TENTS
AND GET YOU GUYS READY.
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> HELLO.
>> HI.
>> IT'S GONNA BE REALLY, REALLY,
LIKE, LIGHT MAKEUP ON YOU.
>> I WANT MOLLY TODAY
WITH A LOT OF HAIR.
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> HEY.
>> HELLO.
>> HI, GIRLS.
>> HELLO. HI.
>> THIS IS YOUNES.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> HELLO.
>> THAT'S HANNAH.
>> MOLLY.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> YOU SMELL GOOD.
>> JUST WONDERFUL.
>> HE SMELLS GOOD?
>> YES.
>> THAT'S A GOOD THING,
'CAUSE HE'S YOUR CO-STAR.
TAKE TIME TO TALK TO HIM
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE TWO OF YOU
CAN MAKE THIS PHOTO WORK,
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA BE
A TEAM EFFORT.
>> MR. JAY DEFINITELY WANTS
TO SEE CHEMISTRY OR CONNECTION
WITH THE MALE MODEL,
WHICH IS PRETTY EXCITING,
'CAUSE I KNOW THAT I CAN
REALLY EMOTE, SO I REALLY FEEL
LIKE I'M GONNA GET
A GOOD PICTURE OUT OF IT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT I'VE NEVER WORKED
WITH A MALE MODEL BEFORE,
SO I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
GONNA EVEN HAVE CHEMISTRY.
I KINDA WANT TO USE HIM
AS MY PROP.
I DON'T WANT HIM
TO MOVE AROUND TOO MUCH.
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL.
BRITTANI HAS BEEN
MORE MY COMPETITION,
BUT HANNAH'S STILL HERE.
SHE IS JUST AS MUCH COMPETITION
AS BRITTANI IS,
AND I GOTTA NAIL
THIS PHOTO SHOOT OR, YOU KNOW,
I'M POSSIBLY GOING HOME,
AND I CAN'T HAVE THAT.
(chuckles)
>> WELL, THIS IS
A BIT OF ADVICE, IN GENERAL.
>> UH-HUH.
>> UH, DON'T THINK ABOUT THINGS
LIKE WHETHER YOU'RE GONNA SIT
OR NOT SIT...
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE THOSE
AREN'T EMOTIONS.
>> YEAH.
>> 'CAUSE ALL YOU REALLY
WANT TO GET IS THAT NARRATIVE.
ALL RIGHTY.
♪♪♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicks)
>> DON'T IGNORE HIM.
ENERGY TO HIM.
CHIN UP TO HIM,
ALMOST, LIKE,
PLAY INTO HIM A LITTLE MORE.
TODAY OF ALL DAYS,
WITH A MALE MODEL,
IN SUCH CLOSE PROXIMITY,
YOU'D EXPECT MOLLY TO BRING IT.
I KIND OF BELIEVE HIS EMOTION
MORE THAN YOURS.
>> LET'S SEE
IF WE CAN GET CLOSER.
>> BUT IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
SHE WAS GIVING KIND OF SEXUALITY
TO A WALL.
LIKE, THERE WASN'T A CONNECTION
BETWEEN HER AND THE MALE MODEL
AT ALL.
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE CHEMISTRY.
>> FEEL HIS BODY.
FEEL THE HEAT OF HIS BODY,
AND THAT'LL HELP.
>> BEAUTIFUL. LIKE THAT.
LOVE THAT.
>> I'M PISSED.
I'M PISSED I DIDN'T DO WELL.
AT THIS POINT
IN THE COMPETITION, I SHOULDN'T
BE DOING BADLY AT ALL.
(crying) I DON'T WANT
TO GO HOME.
I WANT THIS SO BAD.
SO I WAS REALLY UPSET
WITH MYSELF.
>> I DON'T WANT YOU TO BE UPSET.
I JUST WANTED YOU TO KNOW
AT TIMES, YOU FELT
VERY DISCONNECTED.
BUT THERE WERE MOMENTS
THAT REALLY FELT QUITE GENUINE.
HAVE YOU EVEN BEEN
IN THE BOTTOM TWO? YOU HAVE?
SO IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE FEELING
RIGHT NOW, KIND OF?
>> YEAH, I DON'T WANT--I DON'T
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT REALLY UPSETS ME
WHEN I DON'T DO AS WELL
AS I KNOW THAT I CAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANKS, MOLLY.
>> SO WHAT'S OUR FIRST THOUGHT,
DO YOU THINK?
>> I WANNA PULL AWAY FROM HIM,
BUT ANOTHER PART OF ME
LIKES HAVING LOVE THERE.
>> LET'S PLAY WITH THAT
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE'RE GONNA SHOOT
AROUND THESE THINGS HERE.
>> GREAT.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> BEAUTIFUL THERE.
GORG!
I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS THIS--IS THAT STRUGGLE
IS FINE, BUT IT LOOKS
A BIT LIKE A FIGHT.
HANNAH WORKED PRETTY WELL
WITH THE MALE MODEL.
SO OFTEN, THE LOOK ON HER FACE
WAS SO AGGRESSIVE
THAT SHE LOST HER PRETTY.
HOWEVER, I LOVED THE CONCEPT.
I LIKED THE--THE COMMITMENT
TO THE ROLE.
>> YES. SEXY.
BEAUTIFUL, GUYS.
THE CHEMISTRY WAS
REALLY
APPARENT,
BUT SOMETIMES THE EMOTION
TAKES OVER A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
SO IT'S STILL FINDING
THAT BALANCE,
BUT THAT'S A VERY SMALL NOTE.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT MY SHOOT TODAY,
AND MR. JAY REALLY LIKED
WHAT I WAS DOING,
AND I DID EVERYTHING TODAY
THAT I COULD POSSIBLY DO.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> IT'S DO-OR-DIE RIGHT NOW,
REALLY, 'CAUSE I WANNA MAKE IT
TO FINAL TWO SO BAD,
AND I KNOW I CAN DO THIS.
HOPEFULLY IT ALL COMES TOGETHER
THE WAY IT SHOULD.
>> OKAY, GUYS.
WHAT'S THE EMOTION?
>> WELL, I WAS THINKING ABOUT
WE'RE GETTING MARRIED,
AND I'M HAPPY,
AND WE'RE TOGETHER,
BUT THEN I'M SECOND-GUESSING IT.
>> THERE'S THE NARRATIVE.
YOU'RE NOT INTERESTED.
YOU'RE OVER IT. SEE, I LIKE
THAT KINDA "WHATEVER,"
PISSED OFF ALMOST. NICE.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> YOU COULD REALLY KIND OF TELL
THAT BRITTANI HAD
A LITTLE DISDAIN
FOR THE MALE MODEL,
AND BRITTANI STEPPED ON SET
WITH THAT CONFIDENCE OF,
"YOU KNOW WHAT? I KINDA
GOT THIS ONE IN THE BAG."
I'M LOOKING FOR A CONNECTION
AND A STORY.
THE STORY ISN'T BEING TOLD 100%.
WHEREAS WHEN WE WERE
SHOOTING WITH HANNAH...
>> YEAH.
>> HANNAH STAYED IN CHARACTER.
LIKE, EVEN WHEN WE WERE
TALKING TO HER.
>> OKAY.
>> MAYBE DIG INTO
A REAL EMOTION.
>> WHENEVER IT COMES TO BEING
BEING, LIKE, SEXY AND INTIMATE,
I JUST CAN'T DO IT YET.
LIKE, I'M NOT IN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP ACTRESS."
I'VE NEVER TAKEN
AN ACTING COURSE IN MY LIFE.
IT'S JUST, LIKE,
SO FRUSTRATING RIGHT NOW.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> ALREADY MUCH BETTER.
LOVE IT.
BEAUTIFUL. LOVE THE TEARS.
>> BRITTANI SORT OF
BURST INTO TEARS
AFTER JAY SAID SOMETHING TO HER,
AND THE PICTURES
LOOKED STUNNING.
THEY LOOKED BEAUTIFUL.
BUT SHE CAN'T CRY
EVERY TIME SHE GETS PHOTOGRAPHED
IN ORDER TO TRULY EMOTE.
SHE HAS TO PULL FROM WITHIN.
(camera shutter clicks)
WE GOT IT.
>> THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYBODY,
ON THIS WONDERFUL BEACH SHOOT.
>> I PRETTY MUCH SAID
"BRING IT ON" TO THE DAY,
AND I TOTALLY KICKED IT
IN THE ASS
'CAUSE I WAS DOING SOMETHING
THAT THE TWO OTHER GIRLS
WEREN'T DOING, AND I FELT LIKE
COMING OUT OF THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I WAS DEFINITELY
IN A WAY BETTER MOOD
THAN MOLLY AND BRITTANI WERE,
WHICH IS A SIGN IN ITSELF.
>> HE WAS LIKE, "YOU--
IT SEEMED LIKE YOU WERE
TOO CONFIDENT, AND LIKE YOU WERE
LIKE, 'I ALREADY HAVE THIS
IN THE BAG,' AND YOU JUST
CAME TO SET
LIKE IT WAS SOME KIND OF JOKE,"
AND THAT I DIDN'T TELL A STORY
>> I THOUGHT--
>> AND SO THEN I STARTED CRYING
DURING MY SHOOT.
THEY SAID I FINALLY
PULLED IT TOGETHER
ONCE I BECAME VULNERABLE...
(sniffles) BUT BASED
OFF TODAY'S SHOOT, IT'D PROBABLY
BE ME OR MOLLY GOING HOME,
AND I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
(bell tolls)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HI!
MM. HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD.
>> GOOD. GOOD.
>> I HAD TO BE SEWN IN MY DRESS.
IT'S FROM LONDON.
>> AH.
>> YOUR BRASSIERE IS SHOWING.
>> (imitates British accent)
IT'S FROM YOUR TOWN,
THAT'S WHY THE ZIPPER BROKE.
>> DON'T BLAME--WHATEVER--
ZIPPING BREAKING.
>> DO YOU GUYS HAVE
A ZIPPER FACTORY?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THERE THEY ARE.
>> (chuckles)
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> HELLO.
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE
AN ELIMINATION TONIGHT,
AND THERE WILL ONLY BE
TWO GIRLS LEFT--
THE TWO FINALISTS--
OUT OF THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
THAT HAVE TRIED OUT
TO BE IN YOUR VERY SPOT.
YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES--
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS,
A CONTRACT WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THETOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA",
AND YOU'LL GET A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
LIKE OUR CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN,
AND YOU'LL BE FEATURED
ON vogue.it.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES--
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
AND HE'S LOOKING DANDY
THIS EVENING,
AS WELL
AS MR. ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND MR. IVAN BART.
IVAN IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND MANAGING DIRECTOR
OF IMG MODELS.
IVAN LED THE STAR-MAKING
OF LARA STONE,
KAROLINA KURKOVA,
AND GISELE BUNDCHEN.
DON'T YOU WANNA BE
ONE OF THOSE GIRLS?
MM-HMM.
ALL RIGHT.
SO THIS WEEK,
YOU LOVELY LADIES SHOT WITH
OUR NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER.
YOU SHOT
IN THE BEAUTIFUL MOROCCAN TOWN
ON THE COAST.
AND, YOU KNOW, EVERY WEEK,
I EDIT YOUR FILM
AND I LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE SHOT,
AND THEN I DECIDE WHAT IS
THE BEST PHOTO.
I LOVED ALL OF YOUR FILM
SO MUCH,
EVERY GIRL HAS TWO SHOTS.
YEAH!
>> MAKE ME PROUD.
>> SO COME ON DOWN, BRITTANI.
>> SO THE IDEA FOR THE SHOOT,
JUDGES, WAS THAT THE GIRLS
HAD TO EMBODY
AND CREATE THEIR OWN NARRATIVE
FOR A MOROCCAN WEDDING.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR STORY?
>> WE WERE IN A FIGHT,
ME AND, UH, YOUNES,
WHO WAS OUR MALE MODEL.
AND THEN I KIND OF ENDED IT
WITH JUST GETTING
A LITTLE BIT EMOTIONAL
AND VULNERABLE
BECAUSE OF ALL THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN US.
>> THE CHOICE THAT YOU MADE
WAS A REALLY GOOD ONE.
SO HERE IS THE FIRST SHOT.
>> FOR ME, BRITTANI,
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS I HAD
WAS THAT IT'S REALLY BEST
TO START WITH THE EMOTION
AND LET THE STORY FOLLOW.
IT SEEMED LIKE YOU WERE
DOING THE GESTURE
AND THEN SAYING,
"OOH, I'M IN LOVE."
>> YEAH.
>> GREAT PHOTOGRAPHS ARE
A COLLABORATION
OF THE PHOTOGRAPHER
AND THE MODEL,
AND I ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE
THIS PHOTO,
AND I REALLY FEEL GREAT ENERGY.
I THINK YOU DID A FANTASTIC JOB.
>> ALSO, I JUST THINK
THE DELICACY OF THE SLEEVE
AND THE--THE GESTURE OF THE HAND
TO THE MALE MODEL IS WONDERFUL.
>> BUT I HAVE TO AGREE
WITH NIGEL.
REMEMBER TO BE A MODEL
AND NOT TO BE SOLITERAL
WITH YOUR STORY.
ARE WE READY FOR THE NEXT ONE?
>> I LOVE THIS SHOT.
NOW YOU CRIED
RIGHT BEFORE THIS SHOT,
AND I SAID TO YOU,
"GOODNESS. DO YOU HAVE TO CRY
EVERY TIME I SHOOT YOU?"
>> (laughs) IT WAS JUST, LIKE,
EVERYTHING ALL AT ONCE,
AND I WAS JUST, LIKE...
AAH! AND IT CAME OUT.
>> I-I FEEL LIKE, UM,
THAT YOU DIDN'T QUITE GO THERE.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S JUST HALFWAY.
>> THE BELT'S FABULOUS.
I WANT TO HAVE THE BELT.
I THINK THAT IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> TO ME, I HAVE LIVED THIS.
I THINK THIS PICTURE
TELLS YOUR STORY.
OKAY, THANK YOU, BRITTANI.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS HANNAH.
SO, HANNAH, WHAT WAS YOUR STORY?
>> WELL, I TRIED TO PULL
ON HOW I AM.
I'VE ALWAYS KIND OF
PULLED MYSELF AWAY,
AND AT THE SAME TIME,
I WANT TO LOVE THEM,
AND I FELT LIKE THAT WOULD
REALLY, YOU KNOW,
SPARK AN EMOTION IN ME.
>> I THINK IT'S ONE
OF YOUR BEST PHOTOGRAPHS
IN THE ENTIRE CYCLE.
THE BELT--IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
IT'S WAISTED.
>> YOU LOVE A BELT TODAY.
>> I LOVE--WELL, I LOVED
THAT MARIA CRISTINA PETRONE'S,
UH, STYLING,
ALONG WITH NIGEL'S PHOTOGRAPHY,
TAKES IT TO A LEVEL
OF FRANCA SOZZANI'S
ITALIAN "VOGUE"...
>> IT DOES.
>> WHICH IS VERYNECESSARY.
>> YEAH. IT'S INTERESTING.
SEE, WHEN ANDRÉ IS COMPLIMENTING
A PIECE OF CLOTHING,
IT MEANS THAT YOU ARE TAKING
WHAT THE STYLIST PUTS ON YOU
AND YOU ARE SELLING IT,
WHICH IS WHAT A MODEL'S JOB IS.
IT'S TO SELL CLOTHES.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU ARE SUCH AN EMOTIONAL LADY.
>> I DO HAVE, LIKE,
ALL THESE INTENSE EMOTIONS,
BUT THAT'S WHAT MY STRENGTH IS.
I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS
MY WEAKNESS, AND BEING HERE,
I FOUND OUT IT'S MY STRENGTH.
IT'S WHAT MAKES ME UNIQUE.
>> BUT I'VE GOT TO SAY,
IT ALMOST BECAME YOUR PROBLEM,
AND YOU KIND OF GOT
SO INTO THE CHARACTER
THAT EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS DRAMATIC,
YOU LOST YOUR MODEL.
>> SO HERE'S YOUR SECOND PART.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> I WAS TRAPPED,
AND I KINDA LIKE IT.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU--WELL, YOU DID LOVE IT,
DIDN'T YOU?
>> MM-HMM.
>> IT'S STILL THE SAME STORY
TO ME, WHICH IS GOOD.
IT'S THE CONTINUOUS STORY OF,
IT FEELS GOOD,
BUT YOU REALLY WANT TO LEAVE.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE SCARED
TO BE VULNERABLE OR SOMETHING.
>> MM-HMM. I THINK THAT'S GREAT
BECAUSE IT--IT DOES FEEL LIKE
A CONTINUATION OF THE STORY.
>> I ONLY HAVE ONE CRITICISM.
THAT MODEL FOOT
POINTED UP THERE,
THE INVISIBLE HIGH HEEL...
>> MM.
>> IS NOT WORKING FOR ME.
OTHER THAN THAT, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> THE PROBLEM WHEN YOU DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS
IT BECOMES GAUCHE
IN THIS SITUATION.
>> MM.
>> GAUCHE IS THE WORD. EE!
>> IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE--
IT'S WAY TOO OVER-THE-TOP.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LAST BUT NOT LEAST--MOLLY.
>> HELLO.
>> HELLO, MOLLY.
>> HI, MOLLY.
WHAT WAS YOUR STORY
THAT YOU CAME UP WITH?
>> UM, AT FIRST, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE HE ISN'T AS INTO
THE RELATIONSHIP AS ME,
WHICH IS KIND OF
WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH
A LOT OF MY PAST RELATIONSHIPS.
>> IT'S A BEAUTIFUL SHOT,
BUT I'VE GOT TO SAY,
WHEN I LOOKED AT YOU
THROUGH MY LENS,
I FELT THAT I COULD'VE BEEN
THE MALE MODEL IN THE SHOT,
AND THAT'S
WHAT THE VIEWER SEES, TOO.
YOU'VE GOT IT ALL RIGHT.
>> I FEEL THAT PHOTOGRAPHY
IS YOUR STRONG POINT.
YOU'RE VERY GOOD AT THIS.
AND YOUR FACE IS STUNNING.
>> HERE, WHEREAS HANNAH'S FOOT
LOOKED ABSOLUTELY GHASTLY,
HERE, THE FOOT WORKS.
>> I THINK THAT THE SHAPE
OF YOUR BODY APPEALS
TO MEN AND WOMEN.
THERE WERE SOME, LIKE,
SUBTLETIES THAT YOU DID
WHICH WERE SO BEAUTIFUL,
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE TIMES,
NEW GIRLS THINK "I'M IN LOVE."
(gasps) "I'M IN LOVE."
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND THERE WERE SOME
WHERE YOU WERE JUST HOLDING HIM,
AND, LIKE, HE'S, LIKE, HERE
AND YOU WERE JUST LIKE...
OKAY, AND HERE'S
THE SECOND PART OF YOUR STORY.
>> THESE ARE ALL GREAT DECISIONS
THAT YOU MADE,
AND I FOLLOWED YOU.
THE FACT THAT I COULD DANCE
WITH YOU IS WHAT
A PHOTOGRAPHER'S LOOKING FOR.
>> THE CAMERA LOVES YOU,
AND YOU DO GREAT THINGS, MOLLY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I LOVED THAT NIGEL SAID
THAT HE COULD DANCE WITH YOU...
>> (imitates Nigel) DANCE.
>> WHICH MEANS THIS WAS
A COLLABORATIVE MOMENT
BETWEEN THE PHOTOGRAPHER
UNDTHE MODELL,
AND THE FACE IS EXTRAORDINARY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>> NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
THE TWO FINALISTS.
AND THE TWO FINALISTS
WILL BE WALKING
IN A FASHION SHOW
FOR VIVIENNE WESTWOOD,
ONE OF
THEMOST CELEBRATED DESIGNERS
OUT OF ENGLAND.
THANK YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE HAVE THREE GIRLS.
WE NEED TWO FINALISTS
FOR ONE VIVIENNE WESTWOOD
FASHION SHOW.
FIRST UP--BRITTANI.
YOU KNOW, BRITTANI'S,
I THINK, OVER AND OVER AGAIN
DEMONSTRATED THAT SHE CAN MODEL,
THAT SHE CAN PRODUCE
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
BUT THE ACTUAL EXPERIENCE
OF SHOOTING HER
ISN'T THAT ENJOYABLE.
THE SECOND SHOT OF HER--
SHE ACTUALLY DID HAVE TO CRY.
>> IF YOU'RE--IF YOU'RE SAYING
THE PHOTOGRAPHER'S EXPERIENCING
DIFFICULTY SHOOTING A MODEL,
THAT'S THE WORST PHONE CALL
THAT A MANAGER CAN EVER GET.
>> FROM MY POINT OF VIEW,
WHEN I AM IN A MAGAZINE,
AND WE SEE A PICTURE LIKE THIS,
IT'S FABULOUS.
>> I DID A QUICK PHOTO WITH HER.
JUST HER EYES BORING
INTO THAT LENS AT ME
KINDA GAVE ME CHILLS.
HANNAH.
>> HANNAH'S ADORABLE.
SHE WEARS HER EMOTIONS
ON HER SLEEVE.
>> DO YOU THINK SHE'S
STRONG ENOUGH FOR THIS INDUSTRY?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS IRONIC.
>> YEAH.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY IRONIC
THAT SHE THOUGHT
SHE'S STRONG ENOUGH...
>> YEAH.
>> AS SHE ALMOST BROKE DOWN
AND TEARED UP.
>> YEAH.
>> TOTALLY TURNED ME OFF.
>> BUT I'VE BEEN TRAINED
TO--TO SEE THAT ENERGY,
AND THERE WAS SOMETHING
ABOUT HER ENERGY,
THAT OUT OF THE THREE OF THEM,
JUST STANDING THERE,
NOT SAYING A WORD,
SHE WAS RADIATING SOMETHING
THAT, TO ME, WAS A STAR.
>> THIS PICTURE, TO ME,
IS A STAR.
I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S A STAR IN 2011.
MOLLY.
>> SHE IS SHOWING ME
THE CLOTHES, THE BELT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S--
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S CONSCIOUS
EITHER, BUT...
>> CONSCIOUS OF THAT.
>> SHE DOES IT.
>> EVERYTHING ON HER,
YOU WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
WITH A MAGIC MARKER.
>> SHE IS, WITHOUT A DOUBT,
A GREAT PHOTOGRAPHY MODEL,
BUT MOLLY--I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A--
THERE'S A PSYCHIC FEELING, TOO,
WHEN YOU--WHEN YOU FIRST LOOK
AT SOMEBODY, WHAT THEY'RE ABOUT.
>> YEAH, ENERGY.
>> WHAT'S THEIR ENERGY?
I FEEL LIKE
SHE NEEDS TO WORK ON THAT.
>> THIS WEEK, I DID
A LITTLE QUICK IMPROMPTU DANCE
WITH THEM AND PHOTO SHOOT,
AND, YOU KNOW, HAD SOME FUN
AND SOME EMOTIONAL TALK
WITH THEM,
AND SHE WAS LOVELY.
>> SO YOU BELIEVED ALL THAT,
THE ENERGY? OKAY. (chuckles)
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
>> WE HAVE.
>> THREE LOVELY YOUNG WOMEN
STAND BEFORE ME,
AND TWO OF THEM WILL BE WALKING
IN A VIVIENNE WESTWOOD
FASHION SHOW.
I HAVE TWO SETS OF PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
BEST PHOTO GOES TO...
>> MOLLY.
>> (sighs)
>> (whispers indistinctly)
>> SO THAT'S NOT JUST
BEST PHOTOS.
YOU'RE A FINALIST.
>> MM.
>> (gasps) AND YOU COULD
POSSIBLY BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND YOU'RE A FINALIST.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS, SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> HANNAH AND BRITTANI,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
QUITE INTERESTING, YOU TWO,
BECAUSE THE JUDGES DELIBERATED
INTENSELY,
AND THEY HAD
VERY SPECIFIC REASONS
FOR WHY
YOU
AND YOU
WERE THEIR FAVORITES
AND SHOULD BE A FINALIST.
HANNAH, THE JUDGES SAID
THAT YOU HAVE A FACE
THAT CAN SELL, SELL, SELL.
YOUR PHOTOS
THROUGHOUT THIS COMPETITION
HAVE SHOWN THAT A PRETTY GIRL
THAT IS THE GIRL NEXT DOOR
IS AN EDGY GIRL
WHEN SHE HAS THE TALENT
AND THE FIRE INSIDE OF HER.
BUT WHAT THE JUDGES ARE
UNSURE OF
IS THE STRENGTH INSIDE.
AND THEN WE HAVE BRITTANI.
BRITTANI, DOMESTICALLY,
STARTED OFF SO STRONGLY
IN THIS COMPETITION.
THE VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
YOU HAD BLEW ME AWAY,
AND BLEW THE JUDGES AWAY.
BUT WE'VE NOTICED SOMETHING
SINCE YOU HAVE CROSSED
THE ATLANTIC.
AND YOUR PHOTOS
DON'T SEEM TO BE AS STRONG
AS YOUR COUNTERPARTS',
AND IT MAKES US WONDER,
ARE YOU STRONG ENOUGH
TO BE AN INTERNATIONAL MODEL?
SO WHO IS A FINALIST?
>> BRITTANI.
>> (crying)
>> (speaks inaudibly)
>> (whispers) I'LL SEE YOU SOON.
>> (whispers) YEAH.
>> ONE THING
THAT THE FASHION INDUSTRY
DOESN'T TALK ABOUT ENOUGH
IS THE STRENGTH
THAT A MODEL NEEDS
ON THE INSIDE
TO TAKE THE CRITICISM,
TO TAKE THE CRITIQUE,
SO THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
TO SHOW THAT
THAT STRENGTH ON THE INSIDE
CAN BE CONSISTENT
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (sighs) THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE A FINALIST,
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE WALKING
IN A VIVIENNE WESTWOOD
FASHION SHOW.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANKS.
>> AND I LOVED SHOOTING YOU.
SO STUNNING, HANNAH.
AND, HANNAH, AS I SAID,
YOU ARE RARE--
A GIRL THAT CAN LOOK LIKE THIS,
SO WARM AND SO FRIENDLY,
BUT THEN TO BE ABLE
TO GO... (growls)
AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT WE WANT TO FEEL IT HERE.
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY?
>> THANKS, TYRA.
(crying) I'M KIND OF CONFUSED
WITH WHY TYRA
SAID I WASN'T STRONG ENOUGH
BECAUSE I KNOW
I'M--I'M
AN EMOTIONAL PERSON,
BUT I-I'M DEFINITELY PROUD
OF MYSELF.
THIS HAS BEEN
SUCH AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE,
AND NOW I HAVE, LIKE,
THE CONFIDENCE, LIKE,
REALLY TAKE RISKS,
AND I KNOW I CAN SUCCEED.
I JUST WISH I WOULD'VE BEEN
MORE CONSISTENT
WITH MY PHOTOGRAPHS.
AND I WOULD'VE BEEN TOP TWO.
THANKS. THANKS.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> (laughs)
>> SO NEXT WEEK
YOU'RE GONNA BE SHOOTING
YOUR "BEAUTY IN VOGUE" SPREAD.
YOU'RE ALSO GONNA BE DOING
YOUR COVERGIRL PHOTO
AND YOUR COMMERCIAL.
LATER, THE WINNER
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WILL SHOOT
HER ITALIAN "VOGUE" SPREAD.
AND, UM, I'M SO PROUD
OF BOTH OF YOU GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, BYE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> AAH!
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.